the climate agreement that's being
discussed here in Paris is split in two
key sections like finance mitigation and
adaptation one of the areas is called
transparency and that's an area in which
jon niles from the University of
California San Diego has a special
interest what a lot of the public hears
about when you simplify this agreement
is at one point five degrees or is it to
db's that we're going to that's
important but the machinery of what
happens actually is about how we can
measure country's emissions and hold
them accountable to what they said
they're gonna do not see transparency
articles John took me through one
paragraph paragraph six in the article
on transparency to show me how text like
these evolved during negotiations when
we look at the text disagreements here
between countries are categorized into
brackets and options so here's a bracket
here we got brackets shall should other
this is actually they haven't even
decided what countries have to do that's
right so of anything that's in brackets
here is still being actively negotiated
it's still there still disagreement
among parties about what text if any
they're gonna put in the final agreement
stuff that's been agreed is what they
call clean it doesn't have brackets it
doesn't have options what does this
paragraph actually say here I mean what
do we what do we know based on the old
text and what changed to the new text in
the old version when we talked about
what countries were required to report
on to be transparent we didn't even know
what verb we were going to use here at
the UN the old version had brackets
around that verb and it would say shall
provide information should provide
information and then there was a bracket
to send other maybe we can come up with
some other verb maybe somewhere between
shaolin should now five days later on a
cleaner more
holiday to text even though there's
still some disagreements they've agreed
to use the word Chou which is a stronger
word than should okays conduct and this
brings us to the to the options we've
got a Chow an option one but we do have
an option two that's right so we can say
that this paragraph is currently not
clean even though there's no brackets we
still have two competing options they're
just disagreeing about which overall
direction they're gonna take on this
topic so here we've got a very simple
assessment that says people are
countries are going to report option to
actually goes actually contribute a
person shall report shall report and
this is where the language and the
minutiae of these options and brackets
and articles and paragraphs becomes
really important because they're
basically saying the same thing at the
top of the paragraph but the second
option goes into much more details about
what parties move must report out on and
since this is an agreement about
greenhouse gas emissions we really think
that they must report on their
inventories of greenhouse gases as well
as other important information these
options are connected to all the other
options and brackets so if you unwrap
one in a particular way then for this to
work as a 20-year agreement we need to
unwrap or unravel or choose a particular
option that's based on what we unwrapped
somewhere else the complexity of
unraveling
brackets and resolving those options and
making this a legally coherent document
agreement that is not trivial even with
the political will we can still tie
ourselves up and if during that you make
some countries feel like they haven't
been trusted or listened to in this
minutia of the unwinding of the brackets
and the options they can walk away from
this process in this process breaks down
and and you basically did an analysis
for all these brackets and options walk
me through this so what we do is we look
at both the agreement and the ax
decisions and we go through an article
by article paragraph by paragraph on the
key topics and we see how many options
and brackets have been removed over the
course of the past week of negotiations
and the key thing to know is there's
been some progress there's some entire
articles that are clean there's a
diminution or reduction in the number of
options and backers for the diminution
risk complexity that's right reduce
complexity as of now and that's a good
sign but most observers to this process
who've been here for a long time really
wish we were a lot cleaner at this point
because it's going to go to higher
ministers who can't deal with 500
brackets across options and paragraphs
and articles between the agreement and
the decision so we wished it was even
clearer now but we do see clear progress
in reducing the complexity
the new text is out and if we look at
the paragraph we're studying for
paragraph 6 they have in fact resolved
this a particular issue there were two
options now there's one you have settled
for the more detailed option so all
countries are now going to be on the
same page they all have to provide the
same information now if you think about
the overall agreement things have
improved their fewer brackets fewer
options we are now at 29 pages versus 48
before it looks like things are getting
better but they've still got a ways to
go